Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
En Argentina, el INVAP
es una Sociedad del Estado
que desarrolla energía atómica
y tecnología espacial.
Sus satélites viajan alrededor del planeta.
Es el mejor ejemplo, quizá, que tenemos
de la capacidad que tiene
el Estado de innovar.
¿No deberíamos crear un INVAP de la Educación?
Imaginen una agencia pública
que diseñe contenidos y estrategias
para transformar el aprendizaje,
que trabaje con las escuelas para
reescribir lo que pasa en las aulas,
que desarrolle investigación de frontera
para utilizar, por ejemplo,
la inteligencia artificial
en la educación a gran escala.
Una agencia con pedagogos,
diseñadores, científicos de datos,
artistas, filósofos, docentes, muchos de Uds.
Para que esto sea posible
debería estar blindada
de las lógicas políticas de corto plazo.
Deberían llegar los máximos especialistas
y desarrollar una cultura, una mística,
de la innovación en la gestión pública.
El primer paso
es pensar al Estado como posibilidad,
no como la variable de todos los ajustes.
Solo así los cambios en educación
no beneficiarán a los más aventajados.
(Aplausos)